[Music]
on this Saturday night setting the stage
for Alberta's deeply divided election
the heated rhetoric and a last-minute
campaign strategies in the contentious
race the controversial policies and the
consequences for all of Canada the Calm
before Ukraine's counter-offensive the
Russian military
is about to have Holy Hill Unleashed
upon them end or escalation of the war
another shocking allegation of Chinese
interference this time targeting
Canada's former conservative leader
misleading labels and lies I think
companies need to explain themselves the
Dark Side of Green fashion
able National
good evening and thank you for joining
us we begin in the divided province of
Alberta less than 48 hours before a
highly anticipated election that will
shape the province's future and the
countries as well on Monday voters will
decide whether Danielle Smith's United
conservatives deserve to stay in power
despite a slew of controversies or if
Rachel notley and the new Democrats can
have another crack at governing
over the past few days both parties have
been making their final pitches to
squeeze out whatever support they can
get and it all comes down to
Battleground Calgary the city that will
likely decide the fate of the entire
election our Ottawa bureau chief
Mercedes Stevenson just interviewed the
NDP leader and she joins us now good
evening Mercedes what's going on on the
ground and how confident is Rachel
notley
well if we have been talking to
calgarians today as we're walking around
trying to take the Pulse and it is
absolutely a very close race out here
it's right down to the wire Rachel
notley was out trying to stir up the
faithful and join convince those who may
join her uh to come out and vote she
says she's very confident I sat down
with her today and she says going door
to door they're hearing a lot of people
who say they're thinking about voting
for The NDP including some traditional
UCP voters this is what she told me
she's hearing at the doors
the number of people that that have come
to me during this campaign to say this
is the first time ever that I'm going to
vote NDP but I want you to know I'm
doing it and and that's on their own
volition so so it's a pretty common uh
message that's out there from folks and
certainly we're seeing it in some of the
larger and more public endorsements that
we're receiving and um uh yeah you know
we as I say we're pretty optimistic
all right Mercedes now to the issues oil
and gas obviously a big issue in Alberta
when notley was in power at that time
the industry suffered significantly so
what's her position on the future of the
oil and gas industry now
well it's something that the UCP has
repeatedly targeted her on and she has a
very different position than the federal
NDP in fact jug meet sings position on
this has really been an albatross around
her neck in this election as she's gone
forward she says she has a very
different plan for Alberta's oil and gas
and it includes growth including upping
oil production listen to what she had to
say
we support
limiting and reducing emissions we
believe that we can do that while
increasing production we have never
suggested you do that by investing in
the technology
so far a certainly a very different
position there whether or not albertans
are going to believe that a lot are
still bitter about her having introduced
the carbon tax after she was elected in
2015 something that was not a part of
her campaign but at this point it's
really not about the issues and
convincing people anymore it's about the
get out the vote the NDP and UCP both
have to find ways to get people to the
polls who vote for them and to convince
those who are feeling ambivalent and
like there's not really a party they
want to vote for in this to show up and
pick their side we don't have a sense of
what those numbers are but certainly
that's going to be revealed to us on
Monday
all right as the countdown continues to
Monday thanks Mercedes Stevenson from
Calgary
some polls show the UCP with a slight
lead but there are plenty of other
factors that can decide the Victor
joining us now for his analysis is our
chief political correspondent David
Aiken David you're in Edmonton as part
of our decision Alberta coverage team so
what's your sense of the campaign there
in the final days
it is going to be close far and let me
give you the lay of the land as it is in
Alberta this is the right the election
map from 2019. this is all United
conservative blue most of the uh smaller
cities and rural areas went UCP in 2019.
in Edmonton that's the NDP stronghold
these are all the writings in Edmonton
NDP orange unlikely to change on Monday
the really race is going to be in
Calgary this is Calgary in 2019 three
seats for the NDP they're probably going
to pick up at least a half a dozen no
matter what but they need much more than
that they need at least a dozen to win
now over the weekend some big
endorsements former Calgary mayor nahid
nenchi endorsing Rachel notley and the
NDP and Stephen Harper the former prime
minister with his second video of this
campaign endorsing the UCP but
interestingly some business groups The
Business Council of Alberta for example
says this campaign has really been
divisive we've seen some polarization
that's threatening the unity of the
province and they say that could even
threaten Albert economy for us David
clearly this election is important to
albertans but what about the rest of the
country I mean how significant is this
election for our national politics
I think it is significant I'll give you
just one issue climate change we know
from polls that most voters in the rest
of the Country BC Ontario and Quebec
they list climate change as one of their
top three priorities for government but
climate change has really not been an
issue in this particular campaign in
fact both the UCP and NDP leaders have
been talking about expanding and
strengthening the oil and gas sector so
no matter who is Premier after Monday
the Alberta Premier is going to have
some different ideas possibly than the
rest of the country about how to
transform quickly or at all from oil and
gas to something else that's one
secondly if Danielle Smith wins one of
the things she advocated when she won
the leadership of her party was
something she called the sovereignty act
the idea that if Alberta does not like a
federal law then Alberta will not
enforce that law it may not be
constitutional but it's an idea that's
caught on with some other premiers
notably next door Saskatchewan Scott Moe
maybe Quebec's Francois go so if Smith
wins you may also see increased tensions
between Ottawa and Edmonton so it's a
significant election for certainly for
Alberta it's significant for the country
too far
David again in Edmonton thank you for
that analysis David
and global national is hitting the road
starting tomorrow our Donna freezing
will be broadcasting from Edmonton on
Sunday Monday and Tuesday
tune in for coverage of decision Alberta
as voters cast their ballots in one of
the most divisive provincial elections
in years
in Ottawa the debate rages on about
whether to hold a public inquiry into
foreign election interference and New
Revelations are emerging underlining
that threat Global News has confirmed
Canada's spy agency informed former
Federal conservative leader Aaron
O'Toole that he was targeted by the
Chinese Communist Party Aaron O'Toole is
the second MP to learn this tariya isri
reports
as the former conservative leader and a
current Member of Parliament Aaron
O'Toole takes a tough stance on China
there is no greater threat today to
Canada's interests than the rise of
China in world affairs that vote vocal
criticism
his Communist Party a Source close2o
tool confirms thesis informed the
Ontario MP he is being targeted by
Beijing as first reported by The Globe
and Mail I think the fact that members
of parliament former members of cabinet
any Canadian could come under that type
of surveillance threat targeting as it
has been described is massively
concerning O'Toole is not alone another
conservative MP Michael Chong and his
family received threats believed to be
from Beijing this week the former
Governor General and special rapper tour
David Johnston ruled out holding a
public inquiry into foreign election
interference there are so many questions
that are unanswered despite his report
these kinds of issues never go away
eventually an inquiry has to happen in
an op-ed Johnston defended his decision
writing I have never undertaken a
mandate more important than this the
work is not done if people are looking
for
um fast answers to or or more pressure
on the government to improve its game on
foreign interference a Judicial inquiry
doesn't deliver that in in any way shape
or form prime minister Justin Trudeau
insists he will respect Johnston's
recommendation to hold public hearings
instead of a public inquiry but
Trudeau's predecessor thinks Canada is
underestimating the danger in an audio
recording obtained by the globe former
Prime Minister Stephen Harper says
foreign interference is far worse than
we think and warned against naive
globalism and given the threat political
experts fear partisan bickering is only
making Canada more vulnerable this has
now gone off in a lot of different
directions that hasn't allowed us to
focus on the central issue which is the
protection of Canadian sovereignty David
Johnston has agreed to testify before a
parliamentary committee June 6. but
that's unlikely to stop the pressure the
Prime Minister will face next week when
the house returns about why he appointed
a special rapper tour instead of calling
a public inquiry in the first place
Farah
isri and Ottawa thank you for that
Sharia
Ukraine prepares to retaliate
coming up Keith signals a
counter-offensive against Russia is
imminent
plus the new discovery in Egypt
unearthing ancient secrets
[Music]
we are on the eve of what's expected to
be a dramatic shift in the war in
Ukraine a top military official says the
much-anticipated counter-offensive
against Russia is ready to begin Alexi
danilov didn't give a date but as
Channel Shay reports military experts
say this may be the only way for the war
to end
as Russia's war against Ukraine rages on
and more civilians are killed in attacks
like these it now seems clearer than
ever that Ukraine is about to strike
back in a way it hasn't it more than 15
months we know the ukrainians have
prepared their forces and that it should
come very soon that much awaited
counter-offensive which the secretary of
the country's National Security and
defense Council told BBC is coming
in a rare and exclusive interview Alexi
danielov told the broadcaster it could
happen tomorrow the day after or in a
week but you're ready
recapturing lost territory is key for
Ukraine and time matters because support
from Ukrainian allies isn't guaranteed
indefinitely there is a danger of War
fatigue so the the Ukrainian offensive
that could actually bring a sooner end
of the war is really important for
Ukraine and for the world at a meeting
of Baltic leaders and Germany leaders
reaffirm support for Ukraine so if
Russia is just thinking that it could
succeed with its robbery of land of
Ukraine it will not succeed with this
idea and attempt nice to meet you in
Kiev Vladimir zielinski expressed his
gratitude to the United States a major
supplier of military aid and foreign
influence thank you very much thanks
bipartisan support Congress this is the
best money we've ever spent Republican
senator Lindsey Graham met Ukraine's
president as America's own debt ceiling
deadline ticked closer Graham said there
could be no backing off of Financial and
Military Support for Ukraine now but I
expect in the coming days and weeks for
the Ukrainian counter-offensive to yield
results I'm here to tell you
that the Russian military
is about to have holy hell Unleashed
upon them this is a really important
battle for Ukraine it is extremely
important that Ukraine do well in this
offensive
A month's plan counter punch Ukraine
hopes will hasten the end of this war
shuttle Shea Global News
you just heard Sean mention the U.S debt
ceiling dispute well there are signs
tonight that a deal can be reached by
the June 5th deadline to raise the
federal government's 31.4 trillion
dollar debt ceiling top Congressional
Republican Kevin McCarthy says there's
progress with negotiations with
Democratic President Joe Biden as the
nation risks defaulting in just over a
week
look I feel closer to an agreement now
than I did a long time before I because
I see progress but listen this is not
easy in any shape or form and but that
doesn't back us away from it
so a failure by Congress to raise a
self-imposed debt ceiling before June
5th could trigger a default that would
Shake financial markets and send the U.S
into a deep recession
I had identity crisis within the metis
nation the growing dispute fueling
accusations
[Music]
this ancient Discovery out of Egypt has
the world in absolute awe archaeologists
working at the sprawling necropolis of
Sakara part of Egypt's ancient capital
of Memphis the UNESCO world heritage
site Unearthed tombs and workshops
dating back 4 000 years clay pots and
other items used to mummify humans and
sacred animals were also found at the
site
okay back to Canada where deceptive
marketing is illegal but if you're
shopping for clothes while keeping
sustainability in mind you might have
some trouble navigating some trendy
buzzwords like eco-conscious recycled or
Planet friendly this week on the new
reality Kayla McLean explores the rise
in sustainable clothing for sale to
Canadians and how some companies behind
those products are setting themselves
apart
this is the photo shoot for Christy
sumer's latest collection she's the
founder and CEO of Canadian made
clothing brand encircled that looks
great okay now we're going to reverse it
she started the company in 2012 and
about four years in wanted to set the
brand apart from others making
sustainability claims she applied for B
Corp status a private certification that
investigates social environmental and
business practices all at her own
expense
I think of that time I had started
seeing a lot more greenwashing start to
happen a few fast fashion brands had
launched you know conscious Collections
and I was starting to feel a lot more
pressure around that and I could see
that sustainability was becoming a
challenge for us to separate ourselves
from those that were greenwashing
more consumers want sustainable clothing
options and brands are responding
because of that I think everybody's
still trying to figure out what
sustainability means to them as a brand
and that's where Kelly Drennen comes in
you're also a b Corp so that's very
exciting
she is the founding executive director
of Canadian nonprofit fashion takes
action working to advance sustainability
and fashion for more than 16 years
like in anything there's good actors and
there's bad actors the ones who are
doing it properly have the
certifications to back up those claims
or they're being transparent Bob Kirk is
the executive director of the Canadian
apparel Federation representing a wide
range of clothing and manufacturing
companies in Canada
I think companies need to explain
themselves rather than just having a
tagline a simple statement we're green
what is it what does that mean for you
we recommend to our members and to all
companies to be very guarded in what
they say and while other countries are
cracking down on greenwashing including
in fashion for now Canada isn't making
any changes
we don't need to change our laws we just
need to find a way that works for the
competition Bureau and for industry and
ultimately for consumers we reached out
to the competition Bureau to see if it
plans to increase enforcement of
greenwashing and fashion the bureau
declined an on-camera interview and did
not respond to her questions by a
production deadline Farah Kayla McLean
thank you
and as Kayla mentioned you can see more
from her story tonight on the new
reality right here on global and that's
global national for this Saturday night
I'm Farah Nasser and on behalf of our
whole crew I want to thank you so much
for spending part of your evening with
us tonight's your Canada is the Alberta
legislature in Edmonton Donna Friesen
will be live from the Alberta Capitol
tomorrow ahead of next week's provincial
election until next time take care of
yourselves and take care of each other
good night
thank you